hallo
herzlich willkommen in meine taten welt
heute gibt es von mir ein video über
eine von dann torte und die heute etwas
ganz besonderes ich habe sie nämlich für
die libro gemacht von ethos beauty
lounge im innern die torte isst eine
banane mit kuchen mit zart wie takanashi
und dass bananen will kuchenrezepte
kommt in einem anderen vom land video
ich weiß es noch nicht welches sich
zuerst hochladen ob es dieses video oder
das andere auf jeden fall bekommt ihr
das entweder davor oder danach und den
rührteig bin habe ich dieses mal jetzt
unvorbereitet die ganz genauen
mengenangaben zu dieser torte jetzt als
es zu dieser eckigen torte die findet
man auf meinem blog die haben hier zehn
sich extra genannt wenn er die torte in
der gleichen größe machen wollt schaut
einfach auf den block vorbei da stehen
die genauen rezept zutaten und die
zubereitung findet ihr dann wie gesagt
in einem anderen video und jetzt zeigt
sich einfach wie ich den teig in die
form gebe ihnen die eckige form und
werde nach dem backen aussieht und
danach eben wie es weitergeht
die banane rührteig backe ich diesmal in
einer erhebung von und stehen habe ich
jetzt mal nicht mit backpapier
ausgelegte ich hoffe einfach dass da
auch gleichmäßig hoch macht und dann
seht ihr das resultat nach dem backen
der kuchen sieht nach dem backen jetzt
so aus und dann entferne ich diesen bug
rahmen wenn es nicht so einfach geht
einfach mal kurz mit dem messer am rand
entlang und das lasse ich jetzt einmal
komplett auskühlen
nach dem abkühlen wird der kuchen dann
durchgeschnitten und mit peter ganache
gefühlt dieses rezept für die zeit
später gelöscht
findet ihr ebenfalls auf meinem blog das
gibt's zb schon in den cake pops artikel
zu finden ganz unten da stehen die
angaben zu ghana strich aber ich
schreibe ich trotzdem noch mal in dem
jetzigen blogbeitrag dem rhein zu dieser
torte dann ist da nicht zu verwirrungen
kommt vor allem auch wegen der
mengenangabe und das bestreichen der
torte habe ich das jetzt wieder ganz
kurz gehalten im schnelldurchlauf was
euch das mal interessiert wie die torten
ganz glatt bekommt dann schreibt mir
einen kommentar oder einen eintrag bei
facebook dann mach ich das noch mal ganz
genau und schritt für schritt mit euch
der kuren des komplett ausgekühlt und
den setzt sich jetzt auf eine
tortenplatte dafür gebe ich einfach so
ein bisschen ganache auf die
tortenplatte damit der kuchen später
nicht drauf hin und her rutscht und
schön haften bleibt
dann setze ich den kuchen einfach oben
drauf als nächstes schneidig den kuchen
jetzt einmal durch da ich jetzt nicht so
gleichmäßig gebacken aber das soll uns
jetzt mal ganz stören den deckel
vorsichtig weg dann kommt hier jetzt
noch ne ballade drauf das ist einfach so
eine viel frucht minute die verstreicht
ganz kurz und damit noch lecker schmeckt
kommt dann noch ein bisschen ganache
obendrauf und mit der kamera auch so die
kleine unebenheiten ausgleichen
dann setze ich den boden wieder
vorsichtig drauf und streiche noch den
rand mit einer tankkarte ab jetzt muss
ich hier noch den rand mit ghana spülen
und dann kommt noch ganz auf die torte
von joe
und ich setze jetzt auf eine
tortenplatte ich habe jetzt einen kuchen
noch mal ganz klappt gestrichen das habe
ich vergessen mit zu finden
auf jeden fall muss der kuchen da eine
nacht in den kühlschrank damit er ganz
kalt wird und schön glatt bleibt und ich
habe ihm derzeit am schon mal den vom
land eingestellt und wie ich den dann
einen tag später weiterverarbeitet und
gefärbt habt das eigentlich jetzt und
das eindecken die torte geht jetzt auch
im schnelldurchlauf und wie gesagt weder
dazu auch noch ein genaueres video haben
wollt dann meldet euch einfach da mache
ich so eine
schritt-für-schritt-anleitung für euch
bon jovi
aber so
warschau
hallo
donnerstag ist ein guppy in see
und wächst
wie zeigt man uns
wie bitte
die
warum
das tempo ist als ob wir uns sieht es
dort und anschließend zum mediator leben
von safestick wird
can speak
soweit geht es ihnen
o
wandern dann gleichauf liegt dann stellt
sich den kuchen am besten noch mal eine
nacht in den kühlschrank dann kann
nämlich schön die oberfläche am trocknen
und da kann dann auch nichts mehr
passieren durch den transport oder eben
durch den postweg und danach könnt ihr
eigentlich schon die deko aufsetzen die
deko habe ich jetzt schon wieder zwei
tage vorher vorbereitet und trocknen
lassen und ich habe sie komplett aus
blüten passte gemacht damit sie eben
schön hart wird und auch schnell
trocknet er ist ihr blüten passte
trocknen schnell modelliermasse trauben
mit langsamer aber ist in der
verarbeitung einfacher und ich hab jetzt
einfach dem thema entsprechend die
blüten passte ausgerollt und
verschiedene motive ausgeschnitten und
wie ich das gemacht habe und eingefärbt
habe zeige ich euch jetzt einmal im
schnelldurchlauf
guido krebs
prince michael
lieben sie
eine
berlin
auch die
als vorher
habil
die
darin fand
hier
b
es geht nie
grinst er
ob das nicht tun
schicken
von henning feindt
h
an
herr winkler
erwähnt
a
im fall wörz
bio
in fahrt
ohne schaden
b
morning
bis 9
zuletzt wurden
mehr hannover
mal
star ist
sein eindruck sei
der hatte
aus
m
mindestens
ihr baby hoch
fri
die dekoration habe ich dann
anschließend nachdem sie getrocknet war
auf den von hand gelegt und geklebt und
danach habe ich die torte ganz gut
verpackt und sofort verschickt der
bananen will kuchen da hält sich so etwa
vier bis sechs tage da schon ziemlich
saftig und cremig von daher kann man
auch ruhig mal länger stehen lassen und
falls sie jetzt wirklich noch infos über
die details haben wollt oder irgendwie
genauere schritte erklärt haben wollen
dann meldet euch
märz auf jeden fall viel spaß gemacht
diesen kuchen zu backen ich bin froh
dass er heil angekommen ist und gut
schmeckt das hat mir die liebe epo schon
gesagt und ich wünsche euch viel spaß
danach machen falls ihr auch so eine
torte nach macht postet nur eure fotos
auf meine facebook pinnwand und dann
wünsche ich viel spaß dabei und bis zum
nächsten mal